[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde la planification écologique
sera socio-économique ou ne sera pas
planification écologique transition
climatique transition énergétique tout
cela concourt au même objectif de
décarbonation de l'économie de sobriété
de la consommation de réduction des gaz
à effet de serre de contenir le
réchauffement climatique c'est vrai pour
la France comme pour le reste du monde
en ce qui concerne l'Europe un accord
pour une économie neutre en carbone est
prévu pour 2050 avec une étape
intermédiaire en 2030 une écologie de
progrès effective et concrète suppose de
verdir les transports les bâtiments
l'industrie l'énergie l'agriculture à
travers une cinquantaine de leviers
d'action recensé par le plan de
planification écologique dévoilé par le
président Emmanuel Macron que cela soit
souhaitable nécessaire coordonner à
travers les divers secteurs d'activité
est une évidence qui ne se discute pas
reste à savoir si cela est envisageable
avec l'ambition politique proclamée au
regard de la masse considérable
d'investissement évoqué notamment par le
plan Pisani ferie marfous pour France
stratégie et cela alors que la situation
économique de notre pays est tributaire
d'une dette publique supérieure au
produits national brut à un déficit
endémique du commerce extérieur à un
chômage encore élevé et l'Est but not
least aux conflits sociaux qui ont
malmené la société française cette
dernières décennies face à ce challenge
je vais vous présenter mes invités en
leur demandant de faire des propositions
d'action aussi concrète que possible
Jean-René casazenuf vous êtes député
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances à l'Assemblée nationale bris
Lalonde vous êtes ancien ministre de
l'écologie président d'équilibre des
énergies Hélène pesquine vous êtes
architecte urbaniste secrétaire général
duupca Jean-Claude maili vous êtes
ancien secrétaire général de Force
[Musique]
Ouvrière vous venez de voir la citation
de Jean Pisani ferry les politiques
publiques ne seront soutenables que si
l'ensemble de leurs implications
économique et social sont correctement
prises en compte est-ce que vous pensez
monsieur casneuf que la planification
écologique telle qu'elle se présente
pour la France aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'elle est
soutenable alors est-ce que l'objectif
est soutenable mais mais les objectifs
peut-être en prend buul dire que je
trouve qu'on a beaucoup progressé ces
dernières années et beaucoup plus vite
qu'on ne le croit dans votre
introduction vous disiez que tout le
monde était convaincu mais vous saz il y
a encore quelques années on parlait
beaucoup des climatosceptiques et cetera
je crois que donc le constat maintenant
est partagé par tout le monde les les
les le niveau d'investissement
nécessaire B effectivement le rapport
Pisani ferry on va en parler d'ailleurs
60 milliards d'investissements
supplémentaires pour pour pour la France
donc donc maintenant l'enjeu la marche
les marches sont je crois à peu près
partagé par l'essentiel on a aussi
beaucoup progressé et ça c'est le
travail qui a été fait par secrétaire
général général à la planification
écologique c'est répartir cet effort par
secteur répartir cet effort dans le
temps par acteur par sous-action par
levier donc maintenant d'une certaine
manière on sait ce que chacun doit faire
ou que chacun devrait faire pour
atteindre cet objectif de de neutralité
carbone ou et de baisse de des des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
mtenant évidemment la grande question
c'est comment on soutient cette cet
effort quel est le rôle de l'État le
rôle de collectivité territorial le rôle
des entreprises là effectivement c'est
une c'est une montagne c'est un évresse
est-ce que vous pensez que la situation
économique que connaît la
France peut
permettre cette planification écologique
dans son ambition et dans ses
objectifs c'est c'est c'est une grande
question question c'est vrai que quand
vous regardez l'endettement de notre
pays dans les propositions qui sont
faites c'est il faut augmenter
l'endettement s'il y a pas d'accord
européens pour augmenter l'endettement
et
accepter de desserrer un petit peu les
règles européenes on peut pas le faire
tout seul et donc parce que on est déjà
un des mauvais élèves de la classe si
vous me permettez si vous me permettez
l'expression matière d'imposition qui
est aussi un des leviers en matière
d'imposition on est aussi un des pays où
où prélèvement obligatoire est le plus
élevé donc il faut imaginer quelque
chose qui soit probablement au niveau
européen si on veut avoir mais ces
leviers ils existent il faut qu'on les
trouve collectivement oui n peskid
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez mais sur ce
plan-là
c'est-à-dire soutenable économiquement
on regarde la situation du pays et du
fait que le remboursement de la dette
est aujourd'hui le premier budget euh
français avant l'éducation nationale pas
tout à fait mais potentiellement
potentiellement potentiellement voilà je
crois qu'on a un peu tendance sur ce
sujet à se poser mal la question en fait
la question est celle de savoir si le
coût de l'inaction est pas plus élevé
que le coût de l'action oui mais reste
dans la question on est bien obligé
d'investir pour éviter des coûts qui
seront socialisés différemment sans
doute réparti différemment entre les
perdants et les gagnants et qui de toute
façon sont sont maintenant inéluctables
et même sont assez bien aujourd'hui
connus et mesurables quand une
catastrophe intervient et de plus en
plus d'événements climatique génèent des
catastrophes qui ont un coup qu'on s'est
mesuré on voit bien que ce coup-là il à
un moment donné il va falloir le le le
prendre en charge collectivement et donc
dans la mesure où on se dit qu'il vaut
mieux agir que de ne pas agir
effectivement il faut trouver les
leviers financiers pour agir avec une
forme de de de justice dans la
répartition des coûts et des et des
charges qui doit être auss lié il me
semble à la à la répartition des des
comment dire des des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à l'habitant à
l'entreprise ou à la collectivité locale
si on regarde en France la différence
entre les 10 % les plus riches et les 50
% les plus pauvres le budget carbone des
10 % les plus riches à année c'est entre
à peu près 22 tonnes par habitant et par
an et c'est c'est 5 tonnes pour les les
50 % des Français les moins riches donc
il y a quand même aussi une logique de
politique publique qui s'adresse d'abord
à ceux qui sont les plus polluents par
rapport à cet enjeu en tout cas de
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre et
une partie de cette population elle est
très certainement capable encore
aujourd'hui d'être plus mise à
contribution dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le changement climatique dont il
seront également les victimes hein les
riches seront pas moins les victimes que
les pauvres par contre les pauvres le
seront plus vite et et donc je pense
qu'il y a une logique à avoir sans aller
dans les chiffres même de de répartition
de la charge et de la et du poids de de
cet investissement qui il vaut mieux se
projeter dans cette réflexion cette
question là plutôt que dans le montant
qu' va falloir investir et et finalement
le comment dire le niveau du curseur en
valeur absolue et la capacité pour la
France à alors Jean-Claude mai vous avez
des responsabilité sociale importante à
force Ouvrière comment vous répartissez
c'est la priorité entre sociale et
écologie dans un cadre économique qui
est contraint en ce qui concerne la
France et d'ailleurs d'autres pays
européens peut-être à l'exception de
l'Allemagne
oui comme vous le disiez la plus
personne enfin peu de personnes conteste
aujourd'hui la nécessité d'investir de
prendre en compte les questions
environnementales de faire la transition
et cetera mais cette transition comme
d'autres dossiers n'est acceptable que
s'il y a un équilibre aussi s' une prise
en compte des questions sociales euh
vous savez c'est des des trucs très
basiques moi de temps en temps on
m'interroge sur Paris monsieur mai il
faut nous aider parce que 1er janvier
2025 j'ai plus le droit de rouler avec
ma voiture diesel dans Paris alors moi
je peux pas me payer une autre voiture
j'ai pas les moyens je suis retraité et
cetera voilà donc c'est c'est un exemple
hein c'est c'est c'est un épiphénomène
mais en même temps si on ne prend pas en
considération les conséquences sociales
pour les individus et notamment pour
ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens de faire
les travaux dans leurs appartements ou
leurs maisons et cetera ça risque de
créer plus de tension et ça risque
d'être un frein à la transition
écologique donc ça c'est je pense un
élément clé deuxième élément
effectivement c'est le problème
économique dégager il faut les dégager
ces 60 milliards c'est évident mais
comment on fait euh on peut certes comme
le dit le rapport puisanifée allons-y
sur l'emprunt oui d'accord mais à quel
moment les taux d'intérêts vont
redescendre à quel moment ce sera
soutenable financièrement hein il y a
certaines projection qui indiquent enfin
vous pourrez me confirmer ou m'infirmer
que l'horizon 2027 on pourrait être à 75
milliards dans les conditions actuelles
hein de de taux de frais de
remboursement de d'intérêt sur sur notre
dette donc là encore comment on règle ce
problème en situation de croissance qui
pour le moment même si on fait mieux que
l'Allemagne c'est quand même pas
terrible on tourne à 01 et cetera bon au
trimestre euh donc ça ça veut dire poser
les problèmes de fiscalité à un moment
donné moi je suis d'accord à un moment
donné ceux qui ont les moyens ça peut
être du côté des entreprises hein moi je
dis toujours c'est pas nouveau
une grande entreprise peut légalement
être par des systèmes d'optimisation
fiscale payer 8 % d'impôt sur les
sociétés la PME est à 25 voilà bon alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on traite ces
questions ou pas à un moment donné si on
veut financer c'est pareil les réformes
ne passent que si un consentement alors
il est pas à 100 % consentement mais
quand il y a pas consentement on l' vu
sur les retraite ça coince oui alors
bris lalond vous qui avez exercé des
responsabilités ministérielles comment
vous appréhendez la situation présente
sous l'angle
socio-économique d'abord je pense que
c'est un projet enthousiasm pour la
jeunesse française et les Français
décarboné être parmi les premiers à
réussir cette décarbonation la France a
déjà fait la moitié du chemin parce que
on se rend pas assez compte de ça on a
fait la moitié du chemin pour les
objectifs 2030 et et cette année on a
baissé de 4 % déjà c'est inoui on n
jamais baissé autant et donc si vous
voulez c'est apporté voilà voilà c'est
apporté l'ensemble des entreprises du
CAC 40 est mobilisé c'est incroyable
beaucoup plus que dans d'autres
pays alors évidemment il va falloir
prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions et sans doute faut-il
s'évader du carcan européen budgétaire
sans doute faut-il que la transition
écologique ou la
décarbonation fasse fasse l'objet d'un
budget à part un peu comme la libération
on fait à la Caisse nationale de
l'énergie on s'en dette et on rembourse
sur les bénéfices futurs et les revenus
futurs on y arrivera pas autrement et
évidemment il faut qu'il y ait de la
justice sociale et évidemment il y a
beaucoup de maladresse donc corrigeons
les maladresse les afeu pour empêcher
les gens qui sont à la campagne d'entrer
en ville c'est ridicule on a fait une
erreur on n pas on n pas pensé aux
effets pervers même chose pour les
bâtiments et les passeports
thermiques le le le le thermomètre est
mal adapté si vous voulez mais donc on
peut pas tout d'un coup dire aux gens
allez c'est terminer virez partez de là
vous pourrez plus louer c'est pas
possible il faut le faire un peu plus
intelligemment mais c'est parfaitement
possible c'est passionnant et la France
elle est plutôt bien partie
contrairement dire c'est pas une
mauvaise élève si vous regardez les
émissions françaises par habitant par
rapport aux autres pays on est plutôt
bien placé vous avez parlé de carcan
européens la réduction envisagé des gaz
à effet de serre en vue de réaliser la
neutralité carbone en
2050 est-ce qu'elle vous paraît
réalisable
au
regard de ce qu'on attend déjà en 2030
avec une réduction de plus de moitié
est-ce que vous pensez que avec ce qu'on
a fait aujourd'hui cela est réalisable
aujourd'hui c'est réalisable mais on
n'est pas obligé de surenchérir l'accord
de Paris nous dit il faut viser la
neutralité carbone dans la seconde
moitié du siècle l'Europe nous dit on va
pas attendre la seconde moitié du S on
va le faire dès 2050 bon alors bon on
est peut-être à quelques années près
c'est pas vraiment gravissime donc si
vous voulez ce qui compte maintenant
c'est la constance il faut être constant
cohérent et et et et et que ce soit
clair et net pour tout le monde et il
faut surtout pas bouger toutes les 5
minutes parce qu'on a eu tendance à
faire ça beaucoup trop souvent vous
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez est cas neu
sur le ouais j'adore cet enthousiasme je
je je je j'espère que vous avez raison
et je je respecte trop ce que vous avez
fait pour pour pour le mettre en doute
en tous les cas je crois qu'il y a une
prise de conscience moi je une
génération qui était complètement à côté
de la plaque sur le sujet objectivement
et je trouve qu'il y a une monter en
puissance collective moi je crois que on
ne peut réussir que si si tout le monde
participe
c'est pas c'est un sujet que on a
tendance aujourd'hui beaucoup trop en
France à se retourner vers l'état l'État
doit nous aider l'état faire ceci pas du
tout si on veut réussir c'est tellement
important c'est qu'il faut que les
entreprises s'y mettent et elles s'y
mettent faut que les collectivités
territoiales s'y mettent et elles s'y
mettent il faut que les foyers s'y
mettent les français s'y mettent et ils
s'y mettent quelque fois tout seul
quelque fois parce que font les
angueules mais il faut c'est je je
trouve que cette prise de conscience et
ce changement on voit bien le la
sobriété énergétique quand l'année
dernière il y a pas si longtemps on a
dit il faut baisser notre production
notre notre consommation électrique on a
baissé 10 % collectivement parce qu' ça
moi je vis rebondir sur ça parce
que c'est assez intéressant et ça montre
beaucoup de choses il se trouve que
j'étais représentant général de la loi
climat et résilience il y a 2 ans qui
n'a que 2 ans cette loi climat
résilience elle répondait c'est c'est
quoi sa genèse elle répondait aux
attentes des Français la convention
citoyenne d'accord et dans cette loi on
a mis le zan les passeoirs thermiques
les a et feu tous ces sujets dont on
parle bon on nous a engueulé à l'époque
on avait pas respecté à la lettre on av
pas écouté les Français c'était c'était
c'était beaucoup il y avait rien dans
cette loi et cetera et on est en train
de l'appliquer de ou 3 ans après
évidemment on s aperçoit de la
complexité et quand on veut mettre les
CFE on s'aperçoit que effectivement s'il
y a pas d'accompagnement ça se fait pas
quand on veut faire les passeoir
thermique et pourtant Dieu sait qu'on a
prévenu Dieu sait que c'est c'est
échelonné dans le temps Dieu sait que
c'est une toute petite partie mais on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a des difficultés à
le faire et et et je vous parle pas du
Zéro artificiation nette dans les
territoires ruraux comme les miens où on
a l'impression que d'un seul coup on
arrête toute possibilité de
développement dans notre dans notre pays
donc on voit bien
que tout il faut de à la fois il une
sorte d'urgence absolue qui nous dépasse
et à fois il faut beaucoup de de Nuan et
d'accompagnement dans la mise en
placeance parce qu'autrement les mêmes
qui nous ont dit ça pas assz vite mê
attendez ça va beaucoup trop vite
qu'est-ce que vous faites on va
justement parler de cet accomplissement
alors et une pesquine les actions à
envisager sont nombreuses et concernent
les secteurs des transports des
bâtiments de l'industrie l'énergie
l'agriculture est-ce qu'il faut env
envisager toutes ces actions en même
temps et lesquelles prioriser oui alors
moi je je partage l'enthousiasme
justement parce qu'il existe déjà un
certain nombre de solutions en tout cas
pour la partie décarbonation on n'a pas
parlé encore de l'adaptation aux effets
du changement climatique qui sera un
autre enjeu aussi socio-économique
important mais sur la partie baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sur un
certain nombre de de de d'objets
émettant des des du carbone on a
aujourd'hui des solutions elles sont
plus ou moins efficaces à long terme je
pense par exemple à la voiture
électrique qui pourrait remplacer la
voiture thermique on prend a pour la
remplacer par B avec les risques d'effet
perverses de cette solution à à long
terme dont on mesure pas encore bien les
impacts mais peut-être qu'ils vont
arriver à un moment mais en tout cas on
sait relativement bien avoir un effet
rapide sur un certain nombre de ces
émissions de gaz effet de serre sur la
mobilité véhicule lourds comme véhicule
UG avec l'hydrogène peut-être sur les
véhicules lourds sur les bâtiments avec
la rénovation des bâtiments existants
mais aussi le réemploi le recyclage de
l'urbanisation plutôt que l'étalement
urbain qui consomme des TER agricoles
c'est c'est le zéro artificialisation
net don dont vous parliez euh mais aussi
sur des solutions agricoles moins
gourmandes en eau ou moins qui qui qui
préservve le stockage carbone dans les
sols donc c'est ces choses-là sont
connues elles ont un coûp bien entendu
et la question est de savoir comment se
réparti ce coup puisqu'il faut euh assez
rapidement arriver à mettre en œuvre
massivement ces solutions quand il y a
un coup qui est insurmontable ou
insupportable pour un certain nombre de
de décideurs notamment les personnes les
plus modestes il faut trouver euh les
ajustements ou les compensations
nécessaires pour les rendre supportables
et pour moi c'est l'enjeu de la polique
publ de trans même temps où il y a des
priorités moi dir que non seulement il
faut faire tout en même temps parce qu'
il y a l'urgence mais en plus il faut
tester plusieurs solutions en parallèle
je pense par exemple à la mobilité où on
nous parle de mobilité électriqu d'une
part mais avec des enjeux sur les
batteries qui sont pas complètement
durables de mobilité hydrogène d'autre
part qui est pas complètement mature de
mobilité de de non mobilité c'estàdire
de réduire les déplacements en par
exemple en densifiant
l'urbanisation il faut évidemment
prendre toutes les solutions à la fois
parce qu'on a assez peu de temps malgré
tout on parle de l'horizon 2030 et de
l'horizon 2050 c'est moins 10 ans pour
2030 c'est voilà c'est 25 ans pour 2050
on est assez
peu capable de développer des solutions
et de les massifier des nouvelles
solutions qui n'existerait pas
aujourd'hui technologie d'optimisation
et de les massifier à cet horizon là
donc maintenant il faut prendre tout ce
qu'on a sous la main et et tester un peu
toutes les solution à la fois construire
plus sobrement c'est-à-dire moi avec
moins de matièrees première et rénover
l'existant avec les outils quand même
incitatifs financiers qui ont été
largement mis en place par le par le
gouverement merci Jean-Claude mai au
regard des contingences
sociales est-ce qu'il y a des choses
qu'il faut faire avant d'autres ou vous
êtes aussi favorable à ce que tout soit
mis en chantier en même temps mais par
rapport aux besoins des français et non
je pense qu'il y a de enfin moi j'ai
rien contre le fait qu'on mette tous les
chantiers en même temps c'est maintenant
il faut bien comprendre que par exemple
pour Bonner les entreprises les entre
entrepris ont besoin d'une vision à long
terme on peut pas changer tous les 5
minutes d'orientation et cetera dans le
même temps les pouvoirs publics c'est
pas c'est pas d'aujourd'hui hein ça date
depuis longtemps on n pas la culture de
l'évaluation dans notre pays on évalue
parfois on évalue mais on tient pas
forcément compte à part les militaires
avec les retours d'expérience on tient
pas forcément compte des résultats d'une
évaluation on change pas obligatoirement
obligatoirement les choses donc il y a
des exemples ce que citit Bron sur les
passeoirs thermiques et cetera voilà ça
fait partie pour moi d'une politique d'
politique d'évaluation c'est pas
simplement est-ce que ça marche
techniquement c'est est-ce que
socialement les gens sont consentants si
ça marche pas ben on modifie voilà donc
ça c'est sont pour moi des éléments
importants et il faut faire attention
moi je suis par exemple toujours inquiet
aujourd'hui sur l'avenir de l'industrie
automobile dans notrre pays 2035 c'est
quand même court hein faut pas faut pas
l'oublier c'est des transformations
profondes ce sera plus les mêmes métiers
des métiers moins qualifiés on n pas
tout réglé compris que fera-on demain
des batteries électriques et cetera donc
voilà ça c'est des éléments sur sur le
le faudrait pas que l'industrie
automobile devienne la ciderurgie des
années 7080 quoi voilà donc faut être
très faire très très attentif sur ces
question là obligatoirement pour moi les
les trois doivent être pris en
considération les exigences en matière
d'écologie d'environnement les exigences
en matière sociale et les contraintes
économiques et dernier point il a ris
salonda a raison est-ce que on sortira
ou pas des normes européennes bon ça des
discussions en cours au niveau européen
on on verra bien on verra bien ce que ça
donne mais quand on voit par exemple le
dernier texte l'accord passé le 17
octobre sur les questions électriques
tant mieux c'est un progrès mais quand
même c'est bien la technocratie
européenne c'est quand même bien
compliqué oui alors bris LAL vous allez
pouvoir répondre à cette question là des
priorité mais je vous ai trouvé très
enthousiaste oui sur la prise de
conscience comment vous expliquez le
décalage entre cette prise de conscience
enthousiaste et le fait que dans tous
les sondages sur les priorités des
Français ça apparaît loin derrière la
sécurité l'immigration le pouvoir
d'achat et cetera qu'est-ce qu'il et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour faire
remonter la question
écologique il faut nous avons besoin de
de dirigeants enthousiastes qui nous qui
nous donnent de l'espoir qui nous
entraînne et qui nous montre l'avenir
vous voulez dire que les dirigeants
actuels ne donnent pas cette oui
excusez-moi oui en
effet il y a une hésitation et en France
par exemple c'est très frappant par
rapport à d'autres pays la France est
pessimiste on est pour la décroissance
et des choses comme ça vous allez
discutter partout ailleurs en Chine au
Brésil aux États-Unis et cetera les gars
ils y croient ils y croient à la
technique ils croient au progrès ils
croient aux entreprises enfin donc il y
a un effort à faire en France pensez
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas convaincu
par la question je crois qu'il est
convaincu mais allez lui demander c'est
pas à moi qu'il faut qu'il faut demander
n'est-ce pas
je de la République il est un peu
ondoyant comme ça on sait pas très bien
ce qu'il pens hein bon maintenant on a
besoin de ça quelle est la priorité la
priorité c'est l'électrification c'est
c'est assez simple tout le monde est
partage ce constat il faut électrifier
parce qu'on peut produire de
l'électricité de manière décarbonée donc
c'est absolument urgent d'avoir de
l'électricité donc ça veut dire par
exemple le zan on n pas le droit
d'artificialiser la nature mais
excusez-moi mais si on veut mettre des
centrales solaires de de de de de 100
hectares ben il faut bien de la place
pour le faire et donc quelle est la
priorité là discuter est-ce que partout
les espace agricole on la même valeur
écologique ou la même valeur
patrimoniale ou la même valeur même
agricole mais certainement pas donc si
vous voulez il faut il faut là aussi
être flexible intelligent et et choisir
les priorités électrifier donc ça veut
dire produire de l'électricité et puis
ça veut dire consommer de l'électricité
ça veut dire que les voitures
électriques parfait mais les voitures
électriques nos constructeurs ont choisi
des grosses Bagnol pour les riches non
ça c'est pas comme ça qu'on va y arriver
donc il faut des petites voitures pour
pour les français en général hein et ça
va commencer mais c'est seulement
l'année prochaine donc voilà la
difficulté il faut accélérer et en
revanche dans les bâtiments ça stagne on
électrifie pas pourquoi parce que le le
lobby du gaz s'y oppose ah mais il faut
être courageux là un petit peu il faut
dire au gaz et ça suffit le gaz
maintenant maintenant c'est la place au
décarboné donc il faut là aussi de la
volonté et et et il faut s'y tenir mais
il faut être flexible il faut pas il
faut être un peu intelligent quand même
hein ouis hélè Peskine voulez intervenir
oui je vouis dire que la transition
écologique c'est aussi une question de
sécurité et de pouvoir d'achat en fait
dans on pose peut-être mal la question
dans ces sondages en réalité quand le
prix de l'énergie augmenteerit
brutalement ou est menacé ou même on
menace de couper l'électricité ce qui
était le cas au début de l'hiver dernier
les Français se rendent compte assez
vite que finalement ils ont besoin de
modifier leur système de chauffage ou de
réduire leur consommation et ils y
arrivent en plus ils sont volontaires
pour le faire en fait face à des chocs
de pouvoir d'achat justement lié à ces
questions de transition ou de ressources
ou d'approvisionnement il y a pas de
doute sur la solution à entreprendre et
sur la question de la sécurité on a en
ce moment même dans l' Haut- de France
des inondations catastrophiques dans le
Pas de Calais les gens qui ont vécu ces
inondations qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux et dans de plus en plus de
régions aujourd'hui on pense à la vallée
de la Roya derrière Nice et cetera ces
gens-là ils ont quand même en tête que
visiblement leur mode de vie ou leur
manière de de de de de voilà de de de
s'installer sur le sol en France n'est
pas complètement sûr et donc cette
question de sécurité par ailleurs
d'assurance de leur logement de leur
capacité à transmettre leur patrimoine
elle est interrogée par ces enjeux
écologique donc je pense que c'est un
peu compliqué de séparer comme ça les
les questionsou monsieur Jean-René
casenu au regard de vos compétences et
vre fonction comme rapporteur général de
la commission des finances à l'Assemblée
nationale je voudrais vous interroger
sur une proposition du rapport Pisani
ferie marfous pour France stratégie l'
anen commissariat au plan au niveau des
investissements requis et pour arriver
si je peux dire à assumer nos objectif
il propose un impôt exceptionnel pour
permettre et rendre possible la
planification écologique est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à cette proposition et
est-ce qu'elle est réalisable au regard
de la situation
économique si si vous me permettez avant
de répondre directement à votre question
je rebondir sur deux trois petites
choses tout n'est pas qu'un sujet
d'argent je bien que c'est le thème mais
mais tout n'est pas je vais vous prendre
deux deux
exemples de finance on a voté 2
milliards et demi je crois pour ma prime
renove qui donc pour aider on ne les a
pas utilisé en 2023 on vient de faire le
voter le la loi de fin de gestion on ne
les a pas utilisé pas complètement
pourquoi parce que il y a un
accompagnement est-ce qu'on a assez
d'entreprises qui sont formées pour ça
est-ce qu'on a assez de gens qui sont pr
prêt à le faire pour ça donc on aurait
pu doubler ou tripler ce budget là on
aurait été absolument incapable de les
utiliser deuxème point je rebondis sur
ce que Monsieur sur
le notre capacité à nous transformer il
faut se transformer le problème c'est
que la valeur ajoutée si vous voulez
créée par cette transition
écologique
n ne remplace
pas la la la valeur ajoutée actuelle
avec les mêmes person et aux mêmes
endroits et je prends je du sud-ouest
dans l'avyon il y a la fermeture de
cette usine S qui faisait carburateur je
crois pour pour pour le diesel il y a
plus de voiture diesel on ferme on va
recréer de la valeur peut-être avec des
batteries électriques certainement mais
un autre endroit avec d'autres personnes
donc quelle à quelle vitesse socialement
on est capable de former de faire en
sorte que les entreprises se forment et
capable d'accompagner les gens qui qui
vont être victime à un endroit de de
cette de cette transformation alors pour
le financement
moi j'y suis favorable moi j'y suis
favorable mais ça ne peut-être qu'une
réflexion européenne moi et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que pousse à faire Pisan
fé moi j'y suis fa d'abord aujourd'hui
il y a quand même heureusement on n'est
pas non plus vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que les plus riches étaient les
plus grands consommateurs les plus grand
c'est vrai bon c'est émetteur c'est vrai
absolument il quand même aujourd'hui
ceux qui contribuent le plus d'un point
de vue imposition et aujourd'hui les
aides elles sont liées au revenus donc
aujourd'hui vous avez des aides pour
changer de voiture pour changer vos
fenêtres pour changer votre votre votre
chudier et qui sont liés à des à des à
desidment des niveaux de revenus donc
heureusement cette justice sociale est
en place est-ce qu'elle est suffisante
importante on peut en discuter en tous
les cas la la machine la machine est en
place donc oui moi je suis favorable et
ça ne peut-être qu'européen pourquoi ça
peut être européen parce que le niveau
d'imposition en France est quand même
déjà très élevé et donc si vous voulez
sur moi je on se bat notre majorité se
bat là aussi c'est à propos politique
j'en suis désolé mais se bat pour que
notre pays soit attractif d'un point de
vue économique faire en sorte qu'on
réindustrialise notre pays qu'on soit
pas dépendant de Monsieur sur le plan
europen sur le plan européen vous savez
que c'est très difficile regardez
comment ça se passe pour le marché
regardez comment ça se passe pour le
marché de l'électricité regardez les
oppositions de l'Allemagne à
subventionner notre nucléaire décarboné
et cetera alors non mais je voudrais
vous poser quand même une question très
précise oui si on devait imposer est-ce
que vous êtes favorable ce qu'on à ce
qu'on
impose qui est ce que cet impôt
exceptionnel soit porté plus
spécialement par les entreprises qui ont
des dividendes exceptionnelles notamment
au sein du CAC 40 parce que on l'a dit
c'est insupportable pour les classes
moyennes mais est-ce qu'on peut le faire
porter sur certaines catégories écoutez
alors là là je je je je suis désolé de
vous dire ça mais on mélange un peu les
sujets là bon on peut y arriver au au
niveau européen on y est arrivé sur
l'imposition minimale au sein de l'OCDE
aujourd'hui à partir de
2024 vous aurez dans le monde entier un
un niveau d'imposition des entreprises à
15 % minimum est-ce que c'est assez
est-ce que donc on est arrivé à avoir
cette vision globale et la transition
écique c'est un sujet global hein il y a
pas plus global que ce sujet là il y a
pas un sujet qui doit nous réire plus
que ce sujet là donc sur la position il
faut le faire il faut le faire mais
voulez si vous
imposez les entreprises les grandes
entreprises Mo je bien c'est grand donc
c'est épouvantable il faudrait on parle
pas d'épouvantable on parle de
résultat pas
question ma question n'est pas du tout
morale on prend l'argent là où on le
trouve oui les entreprises aujourd'hui
participe évidemment et des
contributions extrê fort c'est le pays
où les prélèvements obligatoires sur les
entreprises et le plus élevé d'Europe ça
devrait nous calmer sur l'efficacité
d'augmentation de l'imposition
évidemment elles doivent mais qu'est-ce
que vous faites si vous si vous avez un
écart d'imposition plus important sur
les entreprises en France que dans les
autres pays européens qu'est-ce qui se
passe les entreprises déménagent c'est
aussi simple que ça et si les
entreprises déménagent vous avez moins
de recett sociales vous avez moins de
recettes fiscales et cetera on a connu
on a fait ça pendant des dizaines
d'années on a été champion du monde de
la fiscalité on a on a eu un chômage
endémique et on a et on a perdu toute
souveraineté d'un point de vue
industriel donc on on n'est pas dans
cette logique là donc oui il faut
chercher des moyens supplémentaires mais
il faut le faire globalement il faut le
faire au niveau européen pour moi c'est
la bonne échelle GL de maïs sur cet
impôt exceptionnel sur cet
investissement ah oui non moi je suis je
suis savorable y compris si cet impôt
doit être temporaire d'une manière ou
d'une autre ça je suis pas opposé mais
enfin globalement on a un problème de
fiscalité en France depuis très
longtemps les gens sont pas à compte
payer l'impôt problème c'est qu'ils ont
le sentiment que ceux qui sont dans la
même situation queeux ou d'autres devrai
payer la même chose payent pas donc il y
a un sentiment profond qui n'est pas
nouveau d'inéquité dans notre système
fiscal est ce qui vaut pour les citoyens
vaut aussi pour les entreprises entre la
PME et la multinationale hein
donc si on travaille pas à un moment
donné sur ces questions là plus
globalement on y arrivera pas ça va être
compliqué mais moi je je suis pour une
imposition exceptionnelle même si elle
est temporaire maintenant c'est vrai que
en économie de
marché la compétitivité ça existe
toujours d'une manière ou d'une autre et
là regardez les Allemands viennent
d'annoncer le gouvernement allemand
vient d'annoncer
aujourd'hui que considérant que
certaines entreprises allemandes sont
venu en France parce que le coût de
l'électricité pour les entreprises est
moins cher un plan de 12 milliards
d'euros de réduction des taxes sur
l'électricité bon ben ça c'est bien dans
une logique qui est purement une lque
logique de compétitivité et l'Europe
c'est quand même un monstre qui est
difficile à bouger quand on est à 27
c'est très compliqué alors bris lalond
on évoque beaucoup l'électrification
vous l'avez vous-même évoqué certains
considèrent et vous-même vous le
considérez que l'électrification
aujourd'hui est une priorité que par
ailleurs de nombreux industriels mais
aussi de grands esprits considère qu'on
ne peut pas
réindustrialiser sans une
électrification est-ce que vous vous
vous seriez favorable à ce qu'il y ait
un impôt ou en tout cas trouver des
investissements pour permettre à la
filière nucléaire française de porter le
projet de la
réindustrialisation
alors ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on ne
réussit pas la décarbonation sans
réindustrialiser et ça c'est un peu
compliqué à faire comprendre notamment à
tous ceux qui veulent la décroissance
c'est que si on veut décarboner il va
falloir électrolyse il va falloir ir des
des pompes à chaleur il va falloir des
batteries pour les bagnoles il va
falloir recycler ses batteries ensuite
donc des usines aussi grandes pour les
recyclates donc il va falloir investir
donc il va falloir en effet faire
attention à ce que les impôts de
production ne soient pas trop élevés
autrement on y arrivera jamais donc là
je suis d'accord avec le rapporteur
absolument donc et et je voulais
reprendre ce que dit Madame madame
madame P pesk oui elle a dit que
peut-être une que la fiscalité pourrait
être aussi ass sur les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre après tout c'est bien
ça le problème c'est le gaz à effet de
serre donc essayons essayons de de de de
de trouver une espèce de combinaison de
moyens de financement si vous voulez il
y a de l'emprunt oui je pense qu'il
faudra emprunter et peut-être qu'on peut
faire un grand un grand emprunt national
français après tout pourquoi pas on a
fait ça dans le temps et peut-être que
les gens seront très heureux de
contribuer à l'effort et puis il y
a les taxes la fiscalité et cetera donc
donc soyons un un peu inventif et
puisque je disis dis au départ c'est que
la limite des 3 % tout ça c'est terminé
quoi ça volet en éclat et donc il va
falloir sortir il faut que la transition
sorte de ces histoires là il faut qu'on
ait un budget à part différent comme on
avait fait après la Libération et
comment on finance la filière nucléaire
française par exemple a besoin de très
gros investissements alors elle a besoin
de très gros investissements surtout
pour me comment ça s'appelle le pour le
nouveau nucléaire non pas pour le
nouveau
pour carinage exactement merci surtout
Besin pour le
carinage le carinage est une chose mais
le discours de bellefort propose 6 + 8
nouveaux réacteurs cela représente une
quantité de milliards d'euros comment
vous financez
ça demander à
EDF cette discussion en ce moment sur le
prix de l'électricité donc une partie de
financement vient du coût de
l'électricité bah qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise il faut à un
moment donné qu'une entreprise il faut
faut que le gouvernement accepte
l'entreprise EDF est une entreprise ou
pas si c'est pas une entreprise alors
c'est un service public c'est
complètement différent c'est une
administration de l'État si c'est pas
une administration de l'État il faut que
normalement dans le prix de
l'électricité elle puisse financer son
son fonctionnement et ses
investissements donc une partie de de ce
financement viendra de là une autre
partie viendra sans doute des aides de
l'État accepté par par l'Union
européenne quand même il y a une chose
très nouvelle dans l'Europe c'est que
elle a elle a compris que c'était pas
uniquement un truc de consommateur
l'Europe c'est aussi un truc de
producteur et pour la première fois
l'Europe a accepté qu'il des politiques
industrielles et ben dans ce dans ce
cadre là je crois que d'ailleurs madame
panierinach s'est beaucoup battu pour ça
je crois que l'Europe accepte maintenant
qu'il y ait des financements dans la
taxonomie hein pour le
[Musique]
nucléaire la penser qu'on a affiché
d'Édouard Philippe il n'y a pas de
démocratie qui subsiste durablement à
une érosion continue du pouvoir d'achat
des classes moyennes alors justement
Jean-Claude maïs ces classes moyennes
voit une stagnation de leur pouvoir
d'achat l'inflation était durable même
si elle a baissé elle reste quand même à
un niveau important les privations au
niveau des consommations même primaires
se manifestent les gens consomme moins
et
cetera comment arriver dans ce contexte
à obtenir le rentiment sur des projets
ambitieux et coûteux il y a deux choses
il
a ce que je de ce que je ressens moi
d'abord c'est BR qui les Français c'est
un peuple pessimiste par rapport à
d'autres moi j'ai une explication pour
ça c'est que le peuple français est un
peuple très politique ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il attend énormément de
ses gouvernants et quand il est déçu de
ses gouvernants et ben on voit ce qu'il
arrive voilà c'est pas ça pas être
aujourd'hui mais mais çaétait c'était
valable hier après la question enfin
c'est vrai que tous les sondages
aujourd'hui montrent que la question
prioritaire numéro 1 dans les réponse au
sondage c'est la question du pouvoir
d'achat même pendant la période actuelle
euh le pouvoir d'achat n'a pas été
maintenu malgré compris quand on regarde
les négociations de salaires telles
qu'elles ont eu lieu dans le secteur
privé encore pire dans le secteur public
hein la perte de pouvoir d'achat est
plus élevé dans le public qu'elle ne
l'est globalement globalement dans le
privé donc il faut savoir répondre à
cette question alors gouvernement a fait
une réunion une conférence sociale il
n'y a pas longtemps je regrette moi que
certaines des décisions qu'il a annoncé
que j'étais avec d'autres on poussé pour
ça depuis depuis pas mal d'années vont
dans le bon sens et pourquoi attendre 6
mois avant de commencer à les mettre en
œuvre quoi je pense au salaire minima
dans les branches par exemple qui
pourrait jouer un rôle de booster de
boost dans les négociation négociation
salarial mais estce ce qui est vrai dir
j'allais dire pour une fois je suis
d'accord avec Édouard Philippe mais
c'est que effectivement la question du
pouvoir d'achat et la dégradation du
pouvoir d'achat des classes moyennes à
un moment donné ça porte atteinte à la
démocratie enfin ça participe à la
montée des populistes quel qu'il soit de
gauche ou droite Jean-Claude ma ici même
dans une émission Daniel Cohen
économiste qui nous a quitté disait
qu'il y avait un
phénomène intéressant d'un point de vue
économique c'est qu'à mesure que le
progrès à l'avance les inégalités
sociales se creusent c'està-dire qu'on
vit cette espèce de contradiction est-ce
que vous vous suggéreriez au
gouvernement de faire une conférence ou
des États généraux sur les inégalités
social qui persiste et qui s'aggrave
dans certaines catégories de la
population sur certains sur certains
points ça a été évoqué lors de la
conférence sociale c'était un des thèmes
de la conférence sociale mais bon il
faut maintenant agir on peut pas se
contenter de dire ben si dans 6 mois les
employeurs ou les branches en question
je prend cet exemple n'ont pas répondu
on sera plus méchant non faut faut faire
les choses faut faire les choses dès
maintenant et la question la question
des inégalités c'est à la fois une
question d'emploi c'est évident même si
le chômage a décliné mais on voit qu'
risque malheureusement de remonter dans
les dans les dans les mois à venir c'est
pour moi toujours une question de de
fiscalité également d' d'inéquité dans
dans la fiscalité et on peut très bien
effecent il y aurait pas bon c'est pas
c'est pas non plus pour la
multiplication des conférences quel que
soit quel que soit leur nom je remarque
quand même bon ça c'est l'ancien qui qui
parle que c'est la première fois qu'une
conférence d' sociale sommet social et
Cera vous appelez ça comme vous voulez
ne soit pas faite en présence du
président de la République donc c'est un
manque oui ça c'est une erreur selon moi
bon Hélène Peskine on va rentrer si vous
voulez dans les
difficultés et dans les propositions
qui peuvent être faites face aux
difficultés socio-économiques que vient
d'évoquer Jean-Claude maili de nos
concitoyens de nombreux responsables
politiques au sein de la majorité
propose de temporiser qui sur la
location immobilière des passoirs
thermiques qui sur l'artificialisation
des sols et de manière plus générale qui
en vienent à considérer que la
transition
écologique et spontanément inégalitaire
pour les classes moyennes qu'est-ce que
vous en penser alors moi je voudrais
dire que le progrès environnemental et
ce sont pas des réactionnaires qui
disent ça si vous voulez je ne veux pas
les citer mais ils sont nombreux je
enfin je pense que le progr je pense
sincèrement que le progrès
environnemental c'est du progrès social
notamment parce que les personnes les
plus fragiles ou vulnérables du point de
vue de l'environnement qui habitent à
côté des autoroutes dans les justement
dans les passeports thermiques qui sont
dans les zones fragilisées par l'érosion
par exemple de du littoral ce sont les
personnes les plus modestes très souvent
les plus pauvre à l'échelle mondiale
comme à l'échelle française donc faire
du progrs environnemental et mettre en
avant la nécessité d'aller vite sur ces
questions environnementales c'est aussi
faire du progrès social à mon avis c'est
un point très important et si on a ça en
tête on peut se dire qu'il y a une
logique finalement de une forme de
redistribution des bénéfices
environnementaux vers les plus fragiles
que je donne un exemple en Allemagne on
a mis en place un billet de train euh
pour prendre donc des transports
décarbonés à 49 € pour tous les jeunes
et tous les personnes qui se déplacent
sur les trains régionaux voilà c'est une
incitation pour les gens qui NT des
classes moyennes ou qui nont pas les
moyens à se déplacer de manière
décarbonée les Espagnols ont fait la
même chose par contre en Grande-Bretagne
on a renoncé à faire un TGV pour aller
dans dans le nord du côté de de
Manchester donc on a quand même des
politiques publiques qui peuvent aller
dans le sens d'une forme de
socialisation du du du bénéfice
environnemental et donc de de faire du
progrès social grâce à ces à ces
transition écologique donc si vous me
posez la question de savoir s'il faut
temporiser moi je suis pas favorable à
temporiser parce que je pense que ça se
fait au détriment des personnes les plus
fr ouais alors j'en r C9 puisque vous
êtes politique vous appartenez à la
majorité présidentielle des responsables
de cette majorité et non des moindres
peut citer Édouard Philippe on peut
citer Jean-Louis bourlange dans une
déclaration récente qui dit la politique
de transition énergétique est une
machine à explosé est-ce que ceux qui
mettent en garde par exemple en disant
euh on ne c'est c'est un problème
difficile à résoudre immédiatement que
d'empêcher la location immobilière de
passepoir thermique ou ceux qui disent
qu'il faut une
artificialisation zéro des sols est
impossible est-ce que vous pensez que
ces gens-là sont des euh des opposants
ou est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a du
bon sens là-dedans non ce sont de deux
personnes formidables mais je pense que
un petit problème de jugement pas de
problème à leur dire s'ils étaient là je
leur dirais aussi aussi franchement on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas ralentir tout
nous dit qu'il faut
accélérer nous qu'on est en
retard des passoir prendre cet exemple
un bon exemple alors c'est quoi ça
concerne qui c passoirs thermiques ça
conçoit ça concerne ceux qui sont
propriétaires de leur de leur maison non
ça concerne les plus pauvres qui lou non
ils en sont les victimes ça ne concerne
que les propriétaire qui font de la
location au moment où ils vont changer
de locataire c'est-à-dire ça va
s'échoner dans le temps on commence par
les vrais passepirs thermiques
c'està-dire j'ai je crois et on parle de
1,7 million de de logement donc pourquoi
on a fait on l' fait ça pourquoi on l'
fait progressivement jusqu'en 2035 je
crois pour les les les parce que
justement que les temps les gens se se
se préparent et puis et on est parti du
principe que quelqu'un qui loue d'accord
quelqu'un qui a un bien et qui le loue
il en tire un revenu c'est pas
complètement an normal qui prenne une
partie de ce revenu pour rénover ça
parce que la principale victime et vous
l'avez très bien dit Madame c'est c'est
quand même la personne qui qui qui qui
est le locataire qui est dans une
passoire thermique et à qui on dit mais
écoutez monsieur dans c'est elle qui
paye c'est elle qui paye c'est elle qui
paye la facture et le propriétaire et le
propriétaire il prend le loyer lui
l'exemple des logements de l'habitat
nous avons fait une émission ici il y
avait un accord
unanime peut-être que c'était orienté je
ne le crois pas politiquement pour dire
que la question du logement elle a été
maltraitée elle reste explosive et
cetera par rapport à l'artificialisation
des sols et au fait qu'il manque
énormément de logement est-ce que vous
direz que c'est un faux problème que de
poser la question comme ça non je pense
que je pense que il faut il faut être
honnête je crois et se dire que cette
transformation écologique elle va faire
mal non mais je si si on pense qu'on va
se faire ça sans sans imposition
supplémenta sans effort sans changer nos
comportements sans changer nos habitudes
on se raconte des
histoires c'est compliqué et ce qui nous
attend est est un effort compliqué il
faut que ce soit réparti le plus
justement possible pour que ce soit
accepté chacun chacun va devoir s'y
mettre si vous voulez et donc sur le zan
bon vous pouvez expliquer ce que c'est Z
artificialisation nette déjà on n'est
pas en train de dire qu'il faut arrêter
du jour au
lendemain que le terme a été mal choisi
donc c'est on dit qu'on veut arrêter
d'artificialiser à horizon 2050 bon et
d'ici là dans les 10 prochaines années
on veut simplement réduire de 50 %
l'artificialisation des sols il y a pas
un mec aujourd'hui qui peut dire que si
on se met à transformer tout tout les
tous les terrains agricoles en résidence
secondaire en parking en je ne sais quoi
c'est bon pour la planète tout le monde
sait qu'il faut arrêter ça et il y a
plein de solutions il y a plein de
friches il y a plein de friches on peut
parfaitement densifier moi je suis dans
un territoire dans les territoires rural
je vais le dire me faire gronder mais il
y a pas un immeuble de deux étages dans
mon département ouis peut-être peutêtre
quelquesuns mais oui donc il y en a très
très très peu donc on peut parfaitement
densifier donc euh les les les usines il
y en a pas beaucoup mais les
établissements industriel si ils sont
ils sont répartis ils sont tous entourés
de parking ils sont tous il faut il faut
il faut concevoir cette cette cette
cette densification et il faut le faire
intelligemment je pense que ça demande
de la concertation il faut le faire avec
les collectivités territoriales il faut
faire avec les acteurs sociaux c'est ça
qui manque probablement euh aujourd'hui
donc les gens voient la décision du
politique ou pas pas et puis ils ont
l'impression d'un seul coup évidemment
il y a toute une série d'agitateurs et
de populistes qui alimentent ses peurs
attention et cetera vous êtes tous
dehors bon la la loi sur le les
passeports thermiques elle serait
responsable aujourd'hui du problème de
logement quand même doucement rigoler
elle s'applique que à partir de 2000 je
sais plus de 2025 je crois bon ouais pas
donc elle est pas du tout responsable et
pourtant ça dire AC le problème pareil
du zan zan les décrets sont toujours
pasessorti on a voté loin pour
effectivement laadapter mais c'est c'est
à cause de ça aujourd'hui quand non donc
je crois que il faut il il y a c'est un
chantier fabuleux et et moi je crois
aussi qu'il est enthousiasment d'accord
comment on adapte notre pays notre
économie euh nos comportements
individuels à à à à cette obligation de
la transition écologique et donc il faut
se fixer des objectifs collectifs et
donc quand c'est un c'est dans la loi
c'est quand même collective c'est la
représentation qui a décidé et puis
après comment on aligne et c'est une
grande complexité qu' on les moyens
comment on les financements comment on
fait cet accompagnement mais mais
reculer aujourd'hui ou freiner
aujourd'hui ne me paraît pas être la
bonne attitude bon ben écoutez on va
conclure là-dessus sur cette question là
euh est-ce que dans la compétitivité
économique mondiale quand on voit les
budgets consacrés par la Chine ou les
investissement des États-Unis notamment
dans l'attraction industrielle la
décarbonation et écologique on se rend
compte que l'Union européenne
peine à aller de l'avant et à se montrer
à son tour
compétitif et beseskine est-ce que vous
pensez que à ce niveau-là un ajustement
notamment avec une taxe carbone mais une
véritable taxe carbone nous permettrait
d'aller de l'avant ou à quel autre moyen
on peut faire appel pour re être
compétitif parce que nous sommes
l'Europe est en face de la Chine en face
des États-Unis dans ce domaine alors ça
a été dit déjà un peu tout à l'heure par
par bris Lalonde effectivement un des
enjeux de la décarbonation c'est de
rapprocher la production de la
consommation et donc d'avoir à proximité
dans l'espace européen de quoi nourrir
le projet industriel énergétique et
écologique européen donc le enfin a
priori la solution idéale c'est la taxe
carbone au frontières tel qu'elle
commence à être mise en re combien je
pourit pas donner un un montant mais en
tout cas il faut donner un prix au
carbone et et considérer que les le
carbone importé doit être au enfin
réduit au minimum dans le monde de de la
consommation en Europe mais ça pose un
certain nombre de questions d'adaptation
par filière par outil par objet par
chaîne de valeur et ça c'est sans doute
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a pas encore bien
fait en Europe par qu'onarrive pas bien
à mesurer à quel endroit de la chaîne de
valeur de une chaîne d'approvisionnement
donné sur un objet ou un outil ou un
équipement industriel on a intérêt à
mettre cette barrière à l'entrée parce
que sinon on risque effectivement de
perdre de la compétitivité par rapport à
d'autres je pense à l'acier par exemple
ou à d'autres à d'autres filières et
donc il a certainement à être un peu
plus subtile sur la manière dont on va
mettre en place et sans doute en
concertation avec ces différentes
filières à l'échelle européenne ces
outils de de taxation frontière mais
enfin pour moi c'est l'outil entre
guillemets idéal le plus le plus
compréhensible par tout c'est le plus
logique pour protéger un espace de
marché qui en plus est le l'espace
marché qui consomme le plus dans le
monde les consommateurs riches en Europe
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est le Graal
de des producteurs américains et chinois
pour pour voilà vendre leur merci
Jean-Claude maïs sur ce point-là
compétitivité comment comment on
l'assure au niveau euréen par je suis
aussi favorable à une taxe carbone à la
frontière européenne quoi ça c'est ça me
paraît évident après c'est pas c'est
effectivement complexe à mettre en place
mais il faut y aller puis je pense que
enfin l'Europe globalement hein
économiquement ou politiquement euh y
compris géopolitiquement on voit bien
qu'en ce moment c'est un un par rapport
aux États-Unis par rapport à la Russie
par rapport à la Chine bon y compris y
compris économiquement et moi je pense
que au-delà des critères qu'il faut
revoir les critères économiques moi je
su longtemps je suis partisan de le ce
qu'on appelle les cercle concentrique il
n'y a aucune raison que des pays au sein
de l'Union européenne que des pays ne
puissent pas décider d'aller plus vite
plus loin y compris sur l'harmonisation
de leur politique fiscale sur
l'harmonisation des politiques sociales
tant qu'on ne travaillera pas ces
questions là on aura toujours beaucoup
de difficultés à prendre une décision au
niveau européen bris lalon taxe carbone
et combien pour que ce soit compétitif
l'un des objectifs de la politique
énergétique c'est la souveraineté et
donc la souveraineté européenne nous est
très importante mais alors comment fait
par exemple toutes les tous les panneaux
photovoltaïques sont fabriqués en Chine
alors il y a des gens qui disent bah
tiens mettant une taxe parce que c'est
ces panneaux photovoltaïques sont
fabriqués avec de l'énergie du charbon
donc le contenu du carbone de ces pneaux
photovoltaïques ne nous convient pas
faisons ça chez nous ça va nous coûter
plus cher mais en même temps si on
disait acceptons d'importer les Panau
photovoltaïques puisque ces Panau phot
photovoltaïques vont contribuer à notre
souveraineté ah c'est compliqué donc en
réalité soyons intelligents voilà c'est
ça le truc final soyons intelligents non
d'un chien oui cas ne sur ce pointl
cette taxe carbone donc on évoque comme
un serpent maire et qui vient pas mais
si ça y est elle a été votée elle est en
train de se mettre ou elle est
compétitive à quel niveau parce que
personne
est en train de se mettre en place c'est
très compliqué elle est son l'acier
enfin bon c'est elle est corrélée au
marché ets de toute manière ça passe par
le marché même l' a été précurseur de ce
votre avis làdessus ça dit que pour moi
ce sujetl les réponses sont européenne
je suis un Européen convaincu si vous
voulez mais sur C et et et effectivement
il faut il faut se protéger faut faire
attention parce que vouz si vous
protégez avec tas carbone les autres
continents font pareil mais je quand on
voit aujourd'hui ce qui se passe d'un
point de vue géopolitique et voilà
l'Europe c'est vraiment le minimum de la
taille fa voudrais vous poser une
dernière question puisque vous
appartenez à la majorité et vous êtes
des fonctions importantes au sein de
cette majorité à votre avis les
élections européennes vont se jouer sur
quoi sur quel thème
essentiel est-ce que par rapport à notre
discussion écologique et sociale vous
pensez que ça fera partie du package
électoral CIS qu'avec ce qui se passe en
Ukraine les questions de sécurité vont
être évidemment extrêmement importantes
avec ce qui se passe euh en Italie en
particulier en Allemagne aujourd'hui les
question
d'immigration vont être aussi centrales
et et
et sujet du pouvoir d'achat il il est
pas que français on est même plutôt
relativement protégé puisqu'on a une
inflation qui est un peu plus faible que
nos pays européens soit plus soft vous
pensez qu'il faut mettre un peu de
climat d'écologie pousser ces questionsl
écoutez moi j'espère j'espère je crois
que l'Europe aujourd'hui est moteur
moteur sur ces sur ces questions là même
d'ailleurs un peu on
on vote en France les lois européennes
avec avec du retard avec de décalage
quelquefis donc quel on est moteur s de
sujet on a été moteur suite à la
citoyenne en particulier ça son de sujet
d'autres on est on est non non il faut
que l'Europe nous aide c'est l'Europe
c'est l'Europe c'est aussi
enthousiasment il faut que l'Europe
reste enthousiasmentilà merci alors
écoutez je vais vous présenter une brève
bibliographie alors je voudrais signaler
le rapport qu'on a longuement évoqué
dans cette émission de jean-pisani ferry
et Selma marfous les incidences
économiques de l'action pour le climat
donc une publication France
stratégie euh je voudrais évoquer un
livre insoutenable inégalité pour une
justice sociale et environnementale de
Lucas chansel édition les petits matins
en deux mots hlen Peskine c'est quoi ce
livre Lucas Chanel c'est un économiste
qui a travaillé avec Thomas picketti sur
le rapport sur les inégalités mondiales
et sa spécialité c'est les inégalités
environnementales et donc son ce ce cet
ouvrage c'est le le la restitution de la
partie du rapport sur les inégalités qui
concernent les vulnérabilités
environnementales et donc c'est une
manière c'est de lui que viennent les
budgets carbones personne en Europe dans
le monde et c'est une manière de de
relativiser la part relative enfin oui
la part relative des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre en fonction du niveau de
vie et des inégalités sociales alors r
Peskine en tant que responsable du PUCA
vous avez de nombreuses publications et
ce qu' en a une dernière qui est en lien
avec les thèmes évoqués oui alors c'est
sur un thème que je voulais évoquer mais
on a pas eu le temps d'en parler qui est
celui de l'adaptation parce qu'en fait
avec l'accélération des effets du
changement climatique on a aussi des
effets qui ont des conséquences social
bien entendu de de vulnérabilité
renforcé d'un certain nombre de
territoires et en l'occurrence on a
travaillé au plusat sur ces territoires
littoraux en outre mer le l'ouvrage
territoire submergé concerne
Saint-Pierre et miiclon et la Martinique
en particulier avec des des des bourgs
qui sont menacés par la montée des eaux
et c'est des questions qui se
rencontrent évidemment dans le monde
entier au bangladèch ou au Vietnam
également avec derrière des enjeux
sociaux et de population qui sont
colossaux et donc cet ouvrage est un peu
un une tentative de de décrire le monde
vers lequel on va finalement à
l'échéance de des effets du changement
climatique merci alors bris lalond je
rappelle que vous continuez à déranger
un petit peu excusez-moi de vous
déranger l'OB il faut encore le
militantisme continue il faut déranger
pour faire prendre conscience des en et
il faut arrêter les guerres voilà 55 5 5
% au moins des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est les tanks les chars les
machin et puis si on fait la guerre on
ferapp va pas on va pas lutter contre le
changement climatique c'est ça c'est ça
qu'il faut il faut arrêter les guerres
merci Briss Lalonde écoutez je vousour
même merci Madame merci messieurs
d'avoir participé à cette conversation à
la fois féconde et fructueuse je
voudrais remercier l'équipe LCP qui a
permis la réalisation de cette émission
et avant de nous quitter vous soumettre
cette pensée de Bertrand Picard qui est
à la fois psychiatre et qui anime la
Fondation Solar Impulse l'écologie peut
aujourd'hui booster l'économie grâce à
toutes les solutions efficientes et aux
opportunités industrielles
[Musique]
propres